more than 30 000 nevadans are affected
by crohn's disease and ulcerative
colitis and currently there is no cure
but this weekend we can take steps to
change that here to tell us about the
spin for crohn's and colitis cures event
is amy burford and the crohn's and
colitis foundation which is with the
clones foundation and her daughter
hannah who is the 2021 patient here good
to see you too good to see you welcome
to the show so amy how has this disease
affected you and your family
it's been a hard long journey she was
diagnosed at the age of two and there
were times where we felt very down very
depressed about the news we got from her
doctors but at the end of the day i
would like to tell
parents to know it's okay to get second
opinions it's okay to ask questions of
your healthcare provider and just be
really supportive of your patient your
child
because it really is an internal battle
it's a it's a whole family affair
everyone is behind your hand and
supporting you how have things been for
you how's your journey been
um it's been a really long difficult
journey uh this disease obviously
affects every aspect of your life so
it's something that you really have to
learn to adapt to and learn how to
change a lot of your habits for me it's
been diet especially
and also how you're just amazing i've
done a couple events so you're so well
spoken i i i admire you and everything
you're doing for the foundation and for
the calls so let's talk about the event
that's coming on coming up on friday
tell us about the details so we're uh
putting on a spin event it's at two
different locations in the valley
summerlin and green valley
you can go to spinfor
dot org las vegas to register 25 per
registration
and it's called party on a bike because
it's supposed to be a really fun time
and to be able to get people out and
having fun we've got so it's at three
locations true fusion downtown summerlin
lifetime in green valley and lvac in
green valley you don't have to be
members to do this you can just sign up
and go and participate correct and so
what's the event like people on their
bikes or riding spinning for a great
cause that's it and the instructors are
kind of like a dj format the instructors
play loud music and they get you going
you don't have to spin to do it i'm
going to be writing and i do not spin
but i'm looking forward to having a fun
time and there's a matching sponsor
correct that's correct so the marshall
family local family here who
unfortunately lost their daughter dana
marshall bernstein to crohn's disease a
few years ago is gonna match up to a
hundred thousand of what we raised whoa
we have to take advantage of that
matching sponsor we've that is huge so
hannah this year you were you were
awarded the 2021 patient hero award what
is that award and what does that mean to
you
um the award was pretty much a
recognition of my personal crohn's and
colitis journey as well as the work that
i've done with the foundation i've done
several years of work with them
and it really meant a lot to me to be
able to get up on that stage i gave a
speech at the event really good by the
way i absolutely crushed it
thank you it really meant a lot to me to
be able to get up on that stage
and help motivate to get more money and
more donations because this really is
a disease that needs more support and
more recognition and this weekend this
friday is a way to take a step in the
right direction to find a cure
absolutely it's always great to see you
too thank you for joining us thank you
spin for crohn's and colitis cures is
happening friday this friday december
3rd for more information visit spin for
dot wait spin 4 dot org
las vegas jillian over to you